this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman Justin
Bieber's a big dick
[Music]
that's right Bieber's terrifying another
nation this week now it's Italy he's
cutting a path of horror through Italy
he had a motorized bicycle that he
illegally parked what a [ __ ] can't
break the law with any balls here's
Justin facing down the female police
officer over his scooter infraction oh
yeah cheers easily the female officer is
like I tried to arrest this lady shorter
pants on
she went to clamber diggers she said Jen
unattractive lady and then be removed
onto the Vatican I'm giving a sermon and
then a Bieber moved on to the Vatican
and he went to the Holy Place and he had
a private tour of the Vatican he paid
twenty six thousand dollars to have a
private tour of the Vatican [ __ ] out
here at which point I [ __ ] kid you
not he started to kick a soccer ball
through the corridors of the Vatican I
mean look I'm one level I'm like you
know what a [ __ ] dick I'm not alive
on my GU rebellion
yeah his repent is kicking a soccer ball
in the Vatican
what 26,000 of a private tour yes and I
want to meet Jesus and take a selfie
like do we tell him like just introduce
him as somebody with a beard
[Laughter]
apparently he irritated staff of the
Vatican when he began to kick a soccer
ball throughout the corridors of the
Vatican Canada we call this soccer I
hate to this little boy Jesus answer my
prayers are killing me Jesus do you hear
me it is your Pope I've never asked you
for shits today I ask you for this one
thing kill this little girl please Jesus
amen as you wish that's not
[Music]
you
[Music]